so i know you're probably getting
asked about this more than anything but
i can't help it because the one
in this is absolutely incredible is
there any one particular beat of that
whole sequence that you found to be the
most challenging
do you know what probably the hardest
the hardest bit of it was was the very
beginning
because you know you hear action you
know that you've got about 30 minutes
with no cuts and you don't want to drop
the ball because if you do you have to
start again you let everyone down
but once you're in it it's like it's
like being on a roller coaster it's just
it's just like because you're free
falling you know you don't know what's
going to happen
most the lines are improvised you know
that you kind of have to be in this
this bit and then go here and then go to
the bath and go to the bedroom
but so it's probably the beginning
because you're just sort of easing in in
from
you know normal reality to sort of the
the play of it i guess
um so yeah i'd say that one because and
then so
you can't really think about that
anymore you can't your nerves just go
because you have to be present
or you know you might something might go
wrong
what do you do to recharge in between
takes cause i think i heard somewhere
you did it
like six times and i mean i i have a
hard enough time
just watching the scene once um
um well yeah because at the end it's
really it's really odd because
in a way you're i guess you're
unconscious like your psyche doesn't
know the difference between real and not
real so
i i took me quite a long time it took me
maybe 10 minutes to sort of come out of
it
and then you know everyone will be
resetting stuff and it's a bit it's a
bit like theater when you do an
afternoon show and then you have an
evening show and you have to kind of
work out how to reset so i'm so lucky
that i've done a lot of plays because
that really helped me but the one thing
that helped the most is we just i
remember we just
had this big speaker and we just blasted
music out you know it was always really
upbeat
like just to change the energy you know
just to make us feel like
that hadn't happened and we're going
back to the beginning and so we and we
danced around the kitchen all of us
and it was uh it just kind of like you
know you kind of like shook the energy
out so
that was it i'm glad to hear you had a
little bit of levity in between
we did yeah what about an unsung hero
of that sequence was there someone who i
don't know had to like
hide under the bed the entire time or
someone doing lighting and sound magic
to keep
equipment out of the shot just someone
that you know a name we don't know that
you really think deserves a shout out
right now
yes the prosthetics team who hid
in the cupboard of the bedroom and they
would have to
like when the i think the camera leaves
the bedroom
and then as the camera was outside the
bedroom while
sean was on the phone the the prosthetic
team would run out and they had to put
you know the baby's head coming out
basically so they had to quickly put
that there so that when the camera came
back they would find it
and the other unsung hero is the actual
baby who was waiting around the corner
with his
parents in the other room and um
[Music]
and he'd be brought in and would be
suddenly there in the scene and so he
was
he was being super quiet and uh we
couldn't have done it without them
so um here is for sure
i still can't get over the whole thing
what do you find
more challenging doing a complicated one
or with all that movement like that
or doing a big emotional beat that's
completely static like the material in
the courtroom
yeah definitely definitely the material
in the courtroom
because i realized having done the birth
i realized that it was
like as you said it was so physical and
it's so uh that your body just has to do
it in a way
your mind doesn't get in the way and i
think one of the biggest challenges of
being an actor is
in the scenes anyway is um
is is trying not to let your mind come
in and
tell you or not doing well or
something's just gone wrong or
you know get in the way or like be
self-conscious and nervous which is
which is so hard to combat most the time
um and so the courtroom is way
way harder way harder to
wrap up here i did want to ask you about
filming
mission impossible just because
everyone's trying to adapt right now and
having had the experience filming during
the pandemic what would you say is
something done on that set that made you
feel like you could deliver your best
possible work
while staying safe that you'd like to
see on more sets now in the future
yeah i think i mean the protocols you
know you get pretty used to them quite
quickly
everyone's always two meters apart um
you know everyone's tested three or four
times a week
it's really rigorous and my sister's
also a member of the crew on the film
she's an ad
she she was on the first film backup
jurassic world in july i think and so i
got to see her do it and
and it was it was it was such a
wonderful moment because
you know the industry had to shut down
and
cinemas were closed and to see
the film set getting back up and running
and people being able to work was a
really
really beautiful thing